FOUR BILLS TODAY ON OUR AGENDA.
ONE HAS BEEN PLACED ON CONSENT.
OUR FIRST ITEM IS AB 1918 BY
SENATOR I'M ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOOD. SO ASSEMBLY MEMBER, IF
YOU'RE READY, YOU MAY PRESENT.
SO GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I'D LIKE TO START BY THANKING
YOU, MR. CHAIR, AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF, FOR YOUR WORK
ON THIS BILL. AB 1918 IS A
DISTRICT BILL THAT ADDRESSES THE
APPLICATION OF CERTAIN CEC
REGULATIONS TO THE TRINITY
PUBLIC UTILITY DISTRICT'S
SERVICE TERRITORY IN TRINITY
COUNTY. TO APPRECIATE THE NEED
FOR THIS BILL, IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND SEVERAL UNIQUE
ASPECTS ABOUT TPWD. UNDER A
FEDERAL LAW ENACTED IN 1955,
TPWD HAS A RIGHT TO HYDROPOWER
GENERATED BY THE TRINITY RIVER
DIVISION OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
PROJECT. ALL POWER DISTRIBUTED
BY TPWD IS GENERATED BY THIS
HYDROPOWER. THIS HYDROPOWER IS
100% CARBON FREE. NO OTHER
UTILITY IN CALIFORNIA DELIVERS
POWER TO ITS CUSTOMERS, WHICH IS
100% CARBON FREE. TPWD ONLY USES
ABOUT A THIRD OF THE HYDROPOWER
TO WHICH IT IS ENTITLED. THERE
IS NO REALISTIC SCENARIO IN
WHICH TPWD WOULD EVER EXCEED ITS
ENTITLEMENT. THE POWER DELIVERED
BY TPWD IS AMONG THE LEAST
EXPENSIVE IN THE STATE. IT IS
LESS EXPENSIVE THAN ROOFTOP
SOLAR. TRINITY COUNTY IS A POOR
COUNTY. SOMETIMES IT'S DEPENDING
ON THE YEAR. IT'S THE POOREST
COUNTY IN THE STATE WITH A
POPULATION OF APPROXIMATELY
15,000 PEOPLE. CONSEQUENTLY,
THERE IS VERY LITTLE NEW
CONSTRUCTION IN TRINITY COUNTY.
ONLY ABOUT THREE NEW HOMES ARE
BUILT EACH YEAR, AND
APPROXIMATELY ONE NEW COMMERCIAL
BUILDING IS BUILT EVERY TWO
YEARS IN THE COUNTY. MY BILL
ADDRESSES TWO CLOSELY RELATED
REGULATORY PROGRAMS THAT REQUIRE
HOMES AND COMMERCIAL BUILDINGS
TO BE CONSTRUCTED WITH SOLAR AND
BATTERY SYSTEMS. THESE PROGRAMS
MAKE LITTLE SENSE IN TRINITY
COUNTY BECAUSE TPWD ALREADY
PROVIDES THE CLEANEST POWER
AVAILABLE TO ITS CUSTOMERS AT
ONE OF THE MOST AFFORDABLE RATES
IN THE STATE. THIS IS
FUNDAMENTAL TO THE RATIONALE FOR
AB 1918. ADDITIONALLY,
REQUIREMENTS IN AB 1918 ARE
SPECIFIC TO THE UTILITY DISTRICT
SERVICE AREA. IT'S EXTREMELY IN
THE EXTREMELY UNLIKELY EVENT
THAT TPWD'S POWER PORTFOLIO EVER
CHANGED, THERE WOULD BE NO
LONGER THEY WOULD NO LONGER
QUALIFY FOR THE EXEMPTION. I'D
ALSO LIKE TO NOTE THAT TEAPOT
HAS RECEIVED TWO TEMPORARY,
THREE YEAR EXTENSION EXEMPTIONS
FROM THE CEC FOR THESE PROGRAMS.
THE MOST RECENT EXEMPTION TOOK
APPROXIMATELY 240 OF TPWD'S
LIMITED STAFF TIME TO HOURS OF
TEAPOTS, LIMITED STAFF TIME AT
SIGNIFICANT COST. IT ALSO CEC IS
HAVING TO SPEND MONEY TO GO
THROUGH AND GRANT THIS EXEMPTION
AS WELL. HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS PAUL HAUSER, GENERAL
MANAGER OF THE TRINITY PUBLIC
UTILITY DISTRICT. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME HERE. IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME, I'M. I WOULD
JUST ADD ON TO, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOOD'S, TESTIMONY THAT, IF WE
DID NOT GET THESE EXEMPTION,
OVERALL EMISSIONS AND COSTS
WOULD GO UP FOR, YOU KNOW, THE
COST WOULD GO UP FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS. YOU KNOW, MONEY
THAT'S SPENT ON A SOLAR SYSTEM
THAT HAS A NEGATIVE RETURN CAN'T
BE SPENT ON ELECTRIC VEHICLE OR
SOME OTHER CARBON SAVING
TECHNOLOGY, YOU KNOW, I'D JUST
LIKE TO POINT THAT OUT, AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU HAVE AND WOULD LOVE TO
SEE AN AYE VOTE AS WELL. THANK
YOU. ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
ORGANIZATION. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIR, AND MEMBERS. DON GILBERT,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN THE ROOM
IN SUPPORT THOSE IN OPPOSITION.
YOU MAY COME FORWARD. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS, KIM
STONE OF STONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SOLAR
AND STORAGE ASSOCIATION, IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION.
TREMENDOUS RESPECT FOR THE
AUTHOR. TRINITY HYDRO. ALL OF
THAT IS GREAT. THE CALIFORNIA
AND SOLAR AND STORAGE
ASSOCIATION, HOWEVER, BELIEVES
THAT THE SOLAR MANDATE IS GOOD
FOR ALL OF US AND FOR CALIFORNIA
, AND EVEN A RIGHTEOUS AND
CARBON FREE UTILITY LIKE
TRINITY. IF THEY MAKE EXTRA
ENERGY, CAN SELL IT TO A
DIFFERENT UTILITY, AND SO
THEREFORE MUST RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THE BILL. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION HERE IN THE ROOM
HEARING, SEEING NONE. THOSE
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS AS IT
RELATES TO THIS MEASURE? WELL,
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM YET.
WE'RE STILL WAITING FOR A
QUORUM. ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOOD, I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THIS
COMMON SENSE MEASURE. AND IT'S
ABOUT TIME WE BRING SOME LEVITY
TO WHAT WE SAY AS OUR PRIORITIES
WHEN IT COMES TO THE ENVIRONMENT
AND ENERGY. HYDRO HAS BEEN ONE
OF THE MOST RELIABLE, RENEWABLE
AND CLEAN ENERGY SOURCES. AND I
REMEMBER WHEN WE STARTED THE
WHOLE PROCESS, HYDRO WASN'T EVEN
CONSIDERED BECAUSE WE WERE
PICKING WINNERS AND LOSERS. WE
WERE DECIDING THAT WIND AND
SOLAR WOULD BE THE BEST OPTION
FOR CLEANING. WHEN WE HAVE SHOWN
FOR DECADES, FOR OVER 100 YEARS,
THAT HYDRO WORKS. IT'S RELIABLE,
IT'S SAFE, IT'S CLEAN. SO THIS
MEASURE MAKES C¢M JUST PRACTICAL
SENSE. AND, I THANK YOU FOR
THAT, AND AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME, WE'LL ASK FOR A MOTION. DO
WE HAVE A QUORUM YET? WE DO NOT.
WE'RE STILL ONE MEMBER SHORT OF
A QUORUM. DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS, VICE CHAIR, AS IT
RELATES TO THIS MEASURE? I DON'T
THINK SO. OKAY, SENATOR WOOD, I
MEAN, ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOOD,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK
YOU. I APPRECIATE THAT VERY
MUCH, MR. CHAIR, THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY A DISTRICT BILL. THIS
THIS POWER COMPANY GENERATES
ONLY USES A THIRD OF THE POWER
THAT THEY GENERATE. CARBON FREE.
THIS DOESN'T IN ANY WAY PREVENT
ANYBODY FROM PUTTING SOLAR ON
THEIR ROOF OF THEIR HOUSE IF
THEY WANT TO, BUT TO REQUIRE
SOMEBODY TO DO IT IN THE FACE OF
THE FACT THAT THEY HAVE ALREADY
GOT 100% CARBON FREE POWER. I'M
SORRY THAT DOESN'T MAKE ANY
SENSE AT ALL. SO WHEN THE TIME
IS RIGHT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND I'M I'M THROUGH THE CHAIR.
I'M ALSO HERE TO PRESENT. YES.
LET ME LET ME SEE IF WE CAN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. WE'RE STILL
WE'RE STILL ONE SHORT. THERE'S
FOUR. YES. NO, THAT'S NINE,
ISN'T IT? WE NEED TEN FOR A
QUORUM. SO WE NEED ONE MORE VOTE
TO GET A BILL OFF THE FLOOR. ALL
RIGHT. ARE YOU ALSO ARE
PRESENTING, FOR, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS, RIGHT? YES. OKAY.
SO GO RIGHT AHEAD. WE HAVE THE
MEASURE IS 27 AB 2779. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. FIRST, I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL AND WILL BE ACCEPTING THEIR
AMENDMENTS. I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY ARE, BUT HAPPY ON THE HAPPY
TO ACCEPT THEM FOR ON BEHALF OF
THE AUTHOR. DANGER WHO YOU ASKED
TO CARRY TO HELP YOU OUT SO AB
2779 WILL REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT SYSTEM OPERATOR TO
REPORT ANY NEW USE OF GRID
ENHANCING TECHNOLOGIES OR GETS
WITH THEIR RELATED COSTS AND
ENERGY SAVINGS, MEANING
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN ENERGY GOALS
WILL REQUIRE AN UNPRECEDENTED
AMOUNT OF PRECEDENTED AMOUNT OF
NEW TRANSMISSION CAPACITY, BUILD
OUT THAT WILL LIKELY BE COSTLY.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE TRANSMISSION,
PLANNING AND PERMITTING PROCESS
IS LENGTHY AND NEW PROJECTS CAN
TAKE OVER A DECADE. I WOULD SAY
EVEN UP TO 12 YEARS OR MORE FROM
CONCEPTION TO COMPLETION, AS THE
STATE REVISES ITS PERMITTING
PROCESS TO GET NEW TRANSMISSION
PROJECTS UP AND RUNNING, INTERIM
SOLUTIONS MAY BE NEEDED FOR
CALIFORNIA TO DELIVER ON ITS
GOALS. GETS ENCOMPASS A SUITE OF
TECHNOLOGIES THAT CAN BE
DEPLOYED ON EXISTING
TRANSMISSION LINES TO MAXIMIZE
OUR CURRENT TRANSMISSION
CAPACITY IN A MORE COST
EFFECTIVE WAY FOR THE SHORT
TERM. WHILE CAISO CONSIDERS
GUESTS IN ITS TRANSMISSION
PLANNING PROCESS, THERE HAVE
BEEN CONCERNS ABOUT THE LACK OF
WIDER ADOPTION IN THE STATE. AS
SUCH, AB 2779 AIMS TO QUELL
CONCERNS BY PROVIDING GREATER
TRANSPARENCY ON THE FREQUENCY
AND BEST USE OF GETS IN
CALIFORNIA, AND HAVING THE CAISO
REPORT ON THE USAGE OF GETS
SELECTED IN THE TRANSMISSION
PLANNING PROCESS HERE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL IS LARA DIÆN WITH
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA. ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB
2779. THANK YOU. YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU. HELLO, MY
NAME IS LARA DIÆN. I'M THE
DIRECTOR FOR ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP AND THANK
YOU TO VICE CHAIR DALI AND TO
ALL THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS, AS
WELL AS ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOOD FOR
PRESENTING THIS BILL ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS.
WE DEFINITELY STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND
OVERALL, THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENTED BY GRID ENHANCING
TECHNOLOGIES AND ADVANCED
RECONSTRUCTING FOR REALLY
UNLOCKING OUR POWER GRID, OUR
CURRENT EXISTING POWER GRID HAS
MUCH MORE POTENTIAL TO CARRY
POWER FROM. YOU KNOW, WHERE THE
POWER SOURCE IS PRODUCED, TO THE
HOMES AND BUSINESSES WHERE
THEY'RE BEING USED, AND ACROSS
THE POND IN THE IN EUROPE,
THEY'VE BEEN USING THESE GRID
ENHANCING TECHNOLOGIES FOR MANY
YEARS AND SEEN MANY, MANY
BENEFITS. BUT HERE IN CALIFORNIA
, WE HAVEN'T UTILIZED TO THE
FULL POTENTIAL THESE THESE
PROMISING TECHNOLOGIES. AND
WE'RE SUPER EXCITED FOR
CALIFORNIA TO REALLY JUMP START
THAT AND START TO EMPLOY THEM
JUST BY, YOU KNOW, REALLY
QUICKLY AND VERY CHEAPLY
INSTALLING SENSORS AND OTHER
DEVICES. WE CAN ACTUALLY THEY
COULD ACTUALLY CARRY TWICE OR
EVEN SOME ESTIMATES QUADRUPLE
THE EXISTING POWER CARRYING
CAPACITY OF TRANSMISSION LINES,
WHICH IS AMAZING. SO HUGE
CHALLENGE AHEAD OF US TO REWIRE
OUR ECONOMY TO BE CLEAN, ENERGY
POWERED AND GRID ENHANCING
TECHNOLOGIES OFFERS A BIG
SOLUTION FOR THAT. SO WE SUPPORT
AB 2779 AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SHINE A LIGHT ON THAT PROCESS
AND HELP MAKE IT HAPPEN. SO
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE WISHING
TO TESTIFY AT ON AS IN SUPPORT?
VICE CHAIR MEMBERS ALICIA PRIEGO
HERE ON BEHALF OF SAN JOSE CLEAN
ENERGY AND SUPPORT. DAN, ON
BEHALF OF AVA COMMUNITY ENERGY,
FORMERLY EAST BAY COMMUNITY
ENERGY AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
MR. VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
JASON IKAT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY CHOICE
ASSOCIATION. ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, MELISSA CORTEZ, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA WIND
ENERGY ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
ANYONE HERE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB 2779? SEEING
NONE, WE WILL BRING IT BACK FOR
DISCUSSION. ANY MEMBERS HAVE
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS? I'LL
MOVE. BILL. WELL, WE DON'T HAVE
A QUORUM YET, SO I JUST WANT TO
I WILL JUST I KNOW THIS ISN'T
YOUR BILL, BUT I DO WANT TO
COMMENT ON WHICH IS SOMETHING
I'VE BEEN FOLLOWING THIS YEAR.
WE HAD THE CEC TO DO REPORTS. WE
ASK THE ISO TO DO REPORTS. THAT
ALL GETS PASSED ON TO THE
RATEPAYERS. THIS IS GOING TO BE
VERY SMALL AMOUNT, BUT THE CAL
ISO OUT ALL THE BALANCING
AUTHORITIES IS THE HIGHEST COST
OF BALANCING AUTHORITIES IN
CALIFORNIA TO DO THEIR BUSINESS.
SO I JUST WANT TO GO ON RECORD
THAT I'M GOING TO BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL. I THINK WE NEED THAT
INFORMATION TO, DO GOOD
RESPONSIBLE GRID, TRANSMISSION
LINE. SO I JUST WANTED TO PUT
THAT OUT. YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU, MR. VICE CHAIR, OBVIOUSLY,
WHEN THE TIME COMES, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE, I THINK JUST
EDITORIALIZING. DANGEROUS. NOT
MY BILL HERE, BUT I'M HERE, SO,
ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO INCREASE
CAPACITY IN THE FACT THE FACE OF
THE FACT THAT IT TAKES SO LONG
TO PERMIT TRANSMISSION IS
REALLY, REALLY IMPORTANT. SO. SO
AS WE MOVE FORWARD, I THINK ANY,
ANY GRID ENHANCING TECHNOLOGIES
SHOULD BE FIND A WAY TO EXPEDITE
THAT THROUGH THE PROCESS AS
WELL. SO RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE WHEN THE TIME COMES.
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
AUTHORS HERE. JIM PATTERSON IF
YOU'RE WATCHING JOE PATTERSON,
IF YOU'RE WATCHING, WE REQUEST
YOU TO BE HERE AT THE ENERGY
BILLS. MR. CHAIR. WE'LL GIVE HIM
AN OPPORTUNITY TO GET DOWN HERE,
AND THEN WE'LL GIVE YOU THAT.
WE'LL TAKE A BREAK, I GUESS,
UNTIL WE GET SOME AUTHORS HERE.
SO I STAND CORRECTED. AB 27 687
IS JOE PATTERSON, WHO IS, THE
LAST BILL WE HAVE.
FOR EVERYBODY IN SANTA CLARITA.
YEAH, IT'S SANTA CLARITA. YEAH.
AND EVERY. SO WE HAVE A AUTHOR
HERE FOR AB 2787. YOU MAY
PROCEED, SIR. GREAT. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR, AND, SENATORS,
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY. MY
FIRST BILL THIS YEAR TO BE IN
THE SENATE. SO LOOKING FORWARD
TO A POSITIVE OUTCOME, HERE TO
PRESENT AB HOPEFULLY I DON'T
WANT TO, YOU KNOW, GET AHEAD OF
MYSELF, HERE TO PRESENT AB 2787,
WHICH WOULD PROVIDE A VERY
TEMPORARY, RELIEF TO PEOPLE WHEN
THEY LOSE THEIR HOMES IN A
WILDFIRE. AND IT WOULD GIVE THEM
THE OPPORTUNITY TÊ TO REBUILD
THEIR HOMES WITHOUT THE SOLAR
BUILDING CODE THAT IS CURRENTLY
REQUIRED ONLY IN THE EVENT THAT
THEY DID NOT HAVE SOLAR ON THEIR
HOUSE ALREADY WHEN THEY LOST
THEIR HOME. WE ALSO PUT MEASURES
IN THERE TO INCOME LIMITS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT TO PROPER
PROTECTIONS, AND AS YOU KNOW, I
REPRESENT AREAS PLACER AND EL
DORADO COUNTIES THAT HAVE HAD
DEVASTATING FIRES, OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS. AND ONE
COMMUNITY ADJACENT TO MY
DISTRICT AND, ACTUALLY PART OF,
THE IN THE SENATOR'S AREA IS,
GRIZZLY FLATS OUT THERE. AND,
AND THAT WHOLE ENTIRE COMMUNITY
BURNED DOWN AND FORTUNATELY AND,
AND WHEN THAT HAPPENED, I WENT I
TOOK A TOUR AND THERE A LOT OF
INDIVIDUALS ARE TRYING TO MAKE A
DETERMINATION ON WHETHER OR NOT
THEY CAN REBUILD. BUT THIS IS A
VERY LIMITED EXEMPTION. AND ALSO
IF THEY HAPPEN TO HAVE
INSURANCE, WHICH HONESTLY IS
MOST PEOPLE, IF THEY'RE ABLE TO
GET IT, IF THEY HAVE INSURANCE,
THEN THIS WOULD NOT APPLY TO
THEM BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW,
INSURANCE REQUIRES THE CODE
UPGRADE COVERAGE. SO THIS WOULD
NOT APPLY TO THEM. THIS APPLIES
TO PEOPLE WHO LEGITIMATELY
CANNOT AFFORD IT. AND ALSO DO
NOT HAVE THE CODE UPGRADE,
COVERAGE. SO WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. DO YOU HAVE ANYBODY
WITNESSES. WE'RE GOING TO HAVE,
SUPERVISOR SUPERVISOR TURN BU
BUT, WE WERE HOPING WE'D BE ON
CONSENT, AND SO WE TOLD THEM TO
STAY HOME INSTEAD OF TAKE THE
DRIVE DOWN. OKAY, SO LET'S TAKE
A BREAK REAL QUICK. AND
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. OKAY.
BRADFORD. DALLI. DALLI HERE.
ASHBY. BECKER HERE. BECKER HERE.
CABALLERO. DODD HERE. DODD.
HERE. DURAZZO. DURAZZO. HERE
EGGMAN. HERE. EGGMAN. HERE.
GONZALEZ. GONZALES HERE. GROVE.
LIMÓN. MINH HERE. MIN. HERE.
NEWMAN. NEWMAN. HERE. RUBIO
CIERTO. SKINNER. STERN. STERN
HERE. WILK. PRESENT. WILK.
PRESENT OKAY, WE'VE ESTABLISHED
A QUORUM. DO YOU HAVE YOU ANY
OTHER WITNESSES WISH TO COME
FORWARD IN SUPPORT OF AB 2787?
SEEING NONE. DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. KIM STONE OF STONE
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOLAR AND STORAGE
ASSOCIATION. WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION. VERY
SYMPATHETIC TO THE FOLKS IN THIS
SITUATION. OUR SUGGESTED
AMENDMENT IS THAT IF FUNDS ARE
AVAILABLE THROUGH THE PUC,
SELF-GENERATION, SGI ÁP
SELF-GENERATION I CAN'T REMEMBER
WHAT THE I STANDS FOR. P
INCENTIVE PROGRAM. THEN, IF
THEY'RE ABLE TO GET FUNDING TO
PAY FOR IT, THEN, THEY WOULDN'T
BE EXEMPT, AND WITH WITH THAT'S
OUR SUGGESTED AMENDMENT. WE
HAVEN'T OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION? SEEING
NONE, WE WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE CHAIR OVER
HERE? YES, SIR, MR. PATTERSON,
GOOD MORNING. SO IT SEEMS LIKE A
REASONABLE AMENDMENT. HOW DO YOU
HOW DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT?
YEAH, WE'VE ACTUALLY I'M OPEN TO
I'VE TALKED WITH THE OPPOSITION
ON THAT AMENDMENTS, BUT I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT IF THERE ARE
AMENDMENTS TO THAT AND WE
CONTINUE TO WORK, THAT THE ONUS
ISN'T PUT ON THE PERSON WHO LOST
EVERYTHING TO ACTUALLY FIND
THESE GRANTS OF BEING AVAILABLE.
I THINK WE NEED A LITTLE BIT
MORE CLARITY ON EXACTLY WHAT
BEING AVAILABLE. I MEAN, IF THE
SOLAR INSTALLER IS ABLE TO
SECURE THAT FINANCING FOR THEM,
THAT'S ONE THING. BUT AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO'S JUST TRYING TO
PUT THEIR LIVES BACK TOGETHER
JUST BECAUSE SOME GOVERNMENT
GRANT IS AVAILABLE SOMEWHERE
THAT THEY MAY NOT EVEN KNOW
ABOUT, IT'S HARD FOR ME TO PUT
THAT SORT OF ON THE PERSON WHO'S
TRYING TO REBUILD. BUT IF THE
SOLAR COMPANY THEMSELVES IS ABLE
TO SECURE THAT FINANCING OR THAT
FUNDING FOR THE SOLAR CUSTOMER,
THEN I'M, I'M GOOD WITH THAT. I
HAVE SOLAR ON MY HOUSE, I LOVE
SOLAR, I THINK THAT'S A THAT'S
AN AMAZING THING. SO IT SEEMS
LIKE A REASONABLE CONCERN. SO,
MISS STONE, I'M SORRY TO MAKE
YOU GET UP HOW TO WORK THROUGH
THE FOLKS ON THAT. I'LL JUST SAY
WE APPRECIATE THE OFFER AND ARE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO ENGAGE IN
CONVERSATION. SO DO SO HERE AND
NOW. ALL RIGHT. THANKS. GLAD TO
MOVE THE BILL WHEN APPROPRIATE.
OKAY, SENATOR STERN, DID YOU
HAVE A QUESTION? OH YEAH. I
WOULD JUST SECOND MY COLLEAGUE'S
POINT. I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S, CONSIDERATION HERE. I
GUESS THE ONLY THING I WOULD
ADD, THE REASON I, I THINK THAT
SOUNDS LIKE A GOOD IDEA IS NOT
TO PUT A BURDEN, BUT BUT TO DENY
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THAT
RIGHT IF THE MONEY IS SITTING
THERE. AND BY THE WAY, THAT
S-CHIP MONEY HAS NOT MOVED
HISTORICALLY, WE WROTE THE
LEGISLATION TO MAKE SURE IT WAS
TARGETED IN FIRE ZONES THAT ARE
IMPACTED BY PSPS SPECIFICALLY
FOR LOW INCOME FOLKS. SO LIKE
THAT MONEY'S FOR THEM. I DON'T
WANT TO DENY THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET THAT UPSIDE.
SO I'M JUST HOPING GOING FORWARD
YOU CAN. YEAH, I'D LOVE TO HEAR
JUST I GUESS WE CAN'T DO THAT
TODAY OR HOW HOW THAT WOULD
WORK. BUT WE'D LOVE TO SEE THAT
HAPPEN. OTHERWISE I, I WORRY
THAT MONEY ITSELF IS GOING TO
GET SWEPT AWAY. RIGHT. AND GO GO
TOWARDS OTHER THINGS. IF WE
DON'T USE IT. SO IT'S KIND OF IN
A USE IT OR LOSE IT PHASE.
ANYHOW, I HAD A LOT OF LOW
INCOME FOLKS IN MOBILE HOMES AND
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT HAD THEIR
HOMES BURNED DOWN, AND WE'VE
SEEN MIXED RESULTS ON THE
PROGRAM. THE GAS COMPANY WAS
ADMINISTERING IT DOWN IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. THEY DIDN'T
GET IT. NOW, FINALLY, THE
ELECTRIC UTILITIES ARE
CONTROLLING IT. SO I THINK PGD
IN YOUR AREA IS THE MAIN
ADMINISTRATOR. SO IF WE CAN GET
IT STREAMLINED, I THINK IT'D BE
GREAT TO ADD ANYWAY. YEAH. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU SENATOR. APPRECIATE
THAT. SENATOR DODD. YEAH. I
THINK, TO SENATOR STERN'S POINT,
IF YOU CAN'T GET IT THROUGH PGD.
AND SO I THINK BEING TOO
PRESCRIPTIVE IN THIS BILL COULD
BE A, COULD BE A PROBLEM BECAUSE
YOU DON'T WANT SOMEBODY ALL OF A
SUDDEN TO THE COUNTY THAT'S
ISSUING THE PERMITS ON THIS. YOU
KNOW, TO SAY I'M SORRY, YOU, YOU
KNOW, YOU HAVE TO DO THIS. SO
I'M NOT OPPOSED TO THE, YOU KNOW
, TO THE AMENDMENT, BUT I THINK
WE'VE GOT TO BE VERY, YOU KNOW,
VERY CAREFUL OF HOW THAT'S
WORDED. IF, IF YOU WANT. WELL,
OKAY, I'M GOING TO PASS THE
GAVEL BACK TO THE, TO THE CHAIR.
BUT I ACTUALLY WANT TO COMMENT
ON THE BILL. SO I ACTUALLY TRIED
TO RUN THIS EXACT SAME BILL A
FEW YEARS AGO. AND THE SOLAR
INDUSTRY KILLED IT. AND I'M VERY
HAPPY TO SEE YOU BRING THIS BILL
FORWARD. AND I WOULD JUST SAY
FROM SOMEBODY WHO HAS HAD THE
CAMPFIRE CAR FIRE OR THE DIXIE
FIRE, I MEAN, I CAN GO DOWN THE
LIST, LITERALLY 12 MEGA FIRES IN
MY DISTRICT IN THE LAST 12
YEARS, AND YOU GO OUT AND TALK
TO THOSE FOLKS AND THEY'RE
TRYING TO REBUILD. AND THE LAW
SAYS THEY HAVE TO PUT SOLAR ON
AND THEY CAN'T AFFORD THE SOLAR
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T HAVE
INSURANCE FOR IT, BECAUSE, AND
WE REALLY NEED TO HELP THEM OUT.
THIS IS A, I THINK, A VERY
COMMON SENSE APPROACH.
OBVIOUSLY, THE OPPOSITION WANTS
TO FORCE THEM TO, TO BUY THEIR
PRODUCTS. AND UNFORTUNATELY,
THESE FOLKS DON'T HAVE TIME TO
GO RESEARCH TO GET A GRANT, AND
IF IT'S AVAILABLE AS THE SENATOR
STERN TALKED ABOUT, SOMEBODY
WILL HELP THEM FIND IT. BUT
DON'T PUT THAT ONUS ON THEM WHEN
THEY'RE JUST TRYING TO GET THEIR
LIVES BACK TOGETHER. SO WE HAD A
I THINK HE LEFT. WE HAD SOMEBODY
THAT WAS GOING TO MAKE A MOTION,
BUT I WOULD BE HAPPY TO MOVE THE
BILL AT THE TIME. SO THANK YOU,
SENATOR CABALLERO. GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MR. CHAIR,
AND I APOLOGIZE I MISSED THE
PRESENTATION, BUT THE QUESTION
THAT I HAD AFTER READING THE
ANALYSIS AND I THINK IT'S A REAL
ISSUE AND I IT MAY NOT JUST BE
SOLAR THAT WE NEED TO LOOK AT,
BUT THE, THE HIGHER COST
REQUIREMENTS THAT COME IN,
BECAUSE, IT'S A TOTAL
DESTRUCTION MIGHT, MIGHT BE
APPROPRIATE AS WELL. BUT SINCE
THIS IS SOLAR, THE QUESTION I
HAD WAS, THE CONDITION THAT THE
OWNER, THAT WOULD DO THE
CONSTRUCTION DID IT. IT WAS
BASED ON INCOME, PERCENTAGE OF
THE INC. THE AVERAGE INCOME
LEVEL OF THE COUNTY. AND I WAS
WONDERING WHY YOU LANDED ON THAT
AS AS A REQUIREMENT. AND THE
ONLY REASON I SAY THAT IS THAT
THE MEDIAN INCOME IN EVERY
COUNTY IS DIFFERENT, AS YOU
KNOW, AND IN IN ONE OF THE
COUNTIES THAT I REPRESENT, IT'S
SOMEWHERE IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF
60 SOME THOUSAND DOLLARS. AND IN
THE NEIGHBORING SANTA CLARA
COUNTY, THE MEDIAN INCOME IS
$110,000. SO, SO IF YOU WERE THE
SAME INDIVIDUAL, BUT YOU WERE ON
ONE SIDE OF THE LINE AS OPPOSED
TO THE OTHER SIDE OF THE LINE,
YOU WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE SITUATION. SO
I'M JUST WONDERING, SURE, IF YOU
YOU THOUGHT ABOUT IT AND I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY. BUT I WAS IT WAS A
CONCERN I HAD. YEAH. WELL THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION, WELL AS A
LOT OF US DO IN THIS BUILDING
AND I'M GUILTY OF IT, I COPIED
AND PASTED A GREAT IDEA FROM A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO AS, SENATOR
DOLLY WAS TALKING ABOUT, BUT BUT
HIS DID ACTUALLY, THAT
LEGISLATION ACTUALLY HAD MORE
FLEXIBILITY IN TERMS OF, IT JUST
HAD TO BE ONE OF THOSE THIS
LEGISLATION SAYS IT HAS TO BE
ALL OF THOSE. THE INCOME
COVERAGE. I ACTUALLY DO ALSO
HAVE CONCERN ABOUT THE INCOME
REQUIREMENT, BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
IF YOU'VE LOST EVERYTHING, BUT
YOUR INCOME HAPPENS TO BE A
CERTAIN LEVEL. WELL, I'M NOT
SURE THAT THAT, YOU KNOW, YOU'RE
JUST TRYING TO REBUILD YOUR
HOUSE. YOU DON'T HAVE INSURANCE,
RIGHT? YOU'RE THE UPGRADE
COVERAGE. BECAUSE IF YOU'RE ON
THE FAIR PLAN, THEY ONLY COVER
10% UPGRADE COVERAGE, WHICH WHEN
YOU'RE UPDATING BUILDING CODES
THAT COULD BE EATEN UP REALLY
QUICKLY. SO PERSONALLY, I WOULD
HAVE SCRAPPED ALL THAT. BUT YOU
KNOW, THIS IS A BUILDING OF
NEGOTIATIONS AND WHAT PEOPLE AND
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE
COMFORTABLE WITH. AND SO THAT'S
KIND OF WHAT WE ENDED, WE ENDED
UP WITH. BUT I DO THINK THIS
WILL HELP PEOPLE, BECAUSE WHEN
YOU GO TO AREAS LIKE THAT THAT
HAVE BEEN BURNED DOWN, I MEAN,
IT REALLY IMPACT ME. SEEING THIS
LADY IN HER 70S SHOVELING SNOW,
LIVING IN HER TRAILER, YOU KNOW,
JUST TRYING TO REBUILD HER
LIVELIHOOD AND DIDN'T KNOW,
FRANKLY, IF SHE WAS GOING TO
REBUILD. AND, HEY, IF I CAN SAVE
HER, YOU KNOW, 20, $30,000, THAT
WOULD BE AN AMAZING THING. AND I
WILL CONCEDE, OBVIOUSLY, THAT IF
THERE'S A PROGRAM AVAILABLE FOR
THEM TO PUT SOLAR ON, I'M A BIG
PROPONENT OF THAT MYSELF. I
SUPPORT, SOLAR IN EVERY REGARD,
ACTUALLY. I JUST DON'T WANT TO
PUT THAT THAT PARTICULAR ONUS ON
ON THE PERSON, THAT LADY WHO'S
LIKE, YOU KNOW, ETCHED IN MY
MIND, I THINK ABOUT HER A LOT,
BUT THERE'S 80 OTHER PEOPLE LIKE
THAT IN THIS ONE COMMUNITY. AND
SO ANYWAYS, THE INCOME LEVEL, I
THINK YOU'RE RIGHT. I MEAN, IF
SOME HOPEFULLY IT NEVER DOES,
YOU KNOW, FIRE IN A HIGHER
INCOME PLACE, YOU KNOW, BUT, YOU
KNOW, I DON'T THINK THAT SHOULD
REALLY BE A CONSIDERATION, TO BE
COMPLETELY HONEST WITH YOU, BUT
I, I TAKE IN COMMENTS FROM THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND THE
SENATORS, AND WHEN THEY HAVE
CONCERNS AND WE TRY TO WORK WITH
THEM. AND THAT'S KIND OF WHERE
WE ENDED UP. I GET IT, YOU YOU
YOU COPIED SENATOR DOLLY'S BILL.
AND I UNDERSTAND COMPLETELY. I
COULD I SHOULD HAVE LEFT IT AT
THAT. YEAH. YEAH I TOOK THE
KING'S, YOU KNOW, BILL AND JUST
RAN WITH IT. I COULDN'T GET IT
DONE. THANK YOU. ARE YOU
REFERRING TO SACRAMENTO KINGS?
HEY, THERE. YEAH ALL THEIR IDEAS
ARE GOOD, BUT I'M STILL GETTING
OVER 2002. SO, YOU KNOW, IT WAS
STILL HEARTBROKEN FROM THAT.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE. THANK YOU
MR. CHAIR, YOU KNOW, I REMEMBER
MR. DALI'S, BILL, AND I REMEMBER
I SUPPORTED IT BACK THEN ONLY
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, AS CHAIR OF
INSURANCE, YOU GET TO HEAR ALL
THE STORIES, YOU KNOW, OF ALL
THE DEVASTATION, HOW PEOPLE ARE
NOT ABLE TO REBUILD. AND, YOU
KNOW, YOU'RE RIGHT. I MEAN,
SOMETIMES WE DO HAVE THESE SORT
OF OLDER GENERATION AND, YOU
KNOW, WE WOULD ARGUE RIGHT NOW
IT'S ALMOST UNAFFORDABLE. SO
EVERYONE THAT DOES HAVE HOMES
ARE USUALLY AND IT'S A BROAD
STATEMENT AND PERHAPS NOT AS
ACCURATELY SAID, BUT OLDER
GENERATION THAT THEY'VE BEEN IN
THEIR HOME FOR SO LONG. AND I
GET THOSE STORIES. AND IT'S
REALLY HEARTBREAKING, ESPECIALLY
BECAUSE THEY'RE SINGLE AS IT
PERTAINS TO EITHER THEIR THEIR
SIGNIFICANT OTHER PASSING AWAY
OR THEIR CHILDREN MOVING AWAY.
AND SO IT'S REALLY DIFFICULT TO
GRAPPLE WITH THE FACT THAT
THEY'RE UNDERINSURED OR NOT
ENOUGH. AND SO I UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO. I REMEMBER
I SUPPORT IT FOR THAT REASON.
WHEN MR. DALI BROUGHT THE TOPIC,
I THINK, A FEW YEARS BACK. BUT
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE FIGURE
THIS OUT BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, IF
THERE'S PROGRAMS WE NEED THEM TO
, TO, TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT.
BUT WE NEED TO HELP IN ANY WAY
WE CAN. SO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. THANK YOU
. ALL RIGHT. ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS BY
MEMBERS, ASSEMBLY. PATTERSON I'M
SORRY I MISSED YOUR
PRESENTATION, BUT I COMMEND YOU
FOR WHAT YOU'RE DOING TO, YOU
KNOW, ALLOW INDIVIDUALS TO
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY AFTER
SOMEONE LOSES THEIR HOME, IS
GETTING THEM REHOUSED AND NOT
PUTTING ON EXTRA BURDENS AND
REQUIREMENTS THAT DIDN'T EXIST
WHEN THEY ORIGINALLY PURCHASED A
HOUSE OR BUILT A HOUSE. SO I
THINK THIS IS A COMMON SENSE
MEASURE, AND IT MAKES
AFFORDABILITY, THE NUMBER ONE
ISSUE BECAUSE, AGAIN, MANY FOLKS
CAN'T AFFORD TO REBUILD AND THEN
TO TACK ON ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS, CGRTS THAT YOU NOW
HAVE TO HAVE SOLAR ON A HOME
THAT DIDN'T HAVE IT FOR THE LAST
50 YEARS. AND I KNOW WE'RE
MOVING TO A GREEN ECONOMY AND
EVERYBODY WANTS A CLEAN
ENVIRONMENT. BUT TO ALLOW FOLKS
TO MAKE THAT CHOICE THAT ARE
MANDATING IT WHEN IT DIDN'T
EXIST, WHEN THEY ORIGINALLY
BUILT THE HOME. AND MANY PEOPLE
WANT LIKE FOR LIKE THEY'RE
COMFORTABLE WITH WHAT THEY HAD.
THEY'RE FAMILIAR WITH WHAT THEY
HAD. SO, I APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE DOING. AND I THINK WE
HAVE A MOTION BY MY SENATOR
DALLI, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
? OKAY. WE HAVE A Dð PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON AB 2787. BRADFORD A, BRADFORD
A DELI. DELI. AYE. ASHBY BECKER.
BECKER. AYE. CABALLERO.
CABALLERO AYE. DODD. DODD. AYE.
DURAZZO. DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN.
EGGMAN. AYE. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ
AYE. GROVE. LIMÓN LEMON. AYE.
GROVE. AYE. MIN A MIN AYE.
NEWMAN. NEWMAN. AYE. RUBIO
RUBIO. AYE. SATO. SKINNER STERN.
WILK. AYE. WILK. AYE ASHBY. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. 1515 TO 0. THAT
MEASURE HAS 15 VOTES. IT'S OUT.
WE'LL LEAVE THE ROLL OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS TO ADD ON. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
EVERYBODY. APPRECIATE IT.
HAVE WE ESTABLISHED THE QUORUM
THEN. YEAH. WE HAVE OKAY. ALL
RIGHT. NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
BACK TO FILE ITEM ONE AB 1918.
WE NEED A MOTION. IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR DALLI. WE HAVE
A Dð PASS THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON HOUSING. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE. DILLY DALLY. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY. AYE. BECKER.
AYE BECKER. AYE. CABALLERO DODD.
DURAZZO. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN
EGGMAN. AYE. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ.
AYE. GROVE LIMÓN. GROVE. AYE.
LEMON. AYE LEMON. AYE. MIN. MIN.
AYE. NEWMAN NEWMAN. AYE. RUBIO.
RUBIO. AYE. SATO SKINNER. STERN.
STERN AYE. WILK. WILK. AYE. 14.
THE MEASURE HAS 14 VOTES. WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR MEMBERS
TO ADD ON. ABSENT MEMBERS TO ADD
ON, NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO AB
2708 BY JIM PATTERSON. WE HAVE A
Dð PASS THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. WE NEED A MOTION
. MOVE. IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR DALLI. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE DELI. DELI. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY. AYE BECKER.
AYE. BECKER. AYE. CABALLERO
DODD. DODD. AYE DURAZZO.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. EGGMAN
AYE. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. GROVE. AYE. LEMON. LEMON.
AYE. MIN NEWMAN. HI MIN. AYE.
NEWMAN. NEWMAN. AYE. RUBIO
RUBIO. AYE. SATO. SKINNER TO
STERN. STERN. AYE. WILK WILK.
AYE. 15 TO 0. 15 TO 0. ON
CONSENT. WE'LL LEAVE THE ROLL
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM THREE AB
2779 BY PETRIE-NORRIS. WE NEED A
MOTION. WE HAVE A Dð PASS, AS
AMENDED TO SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. IT'S BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR MANN. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE. DALLI. DALLI. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY AYE. BECKER.
BECKER. AYE. CABALLERO DODD.
AYE. DODD. AYE OSO. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
GROVE. AYE. LEMON LEMON. AYE.
MIN A MIN. AYE. NEWMAN AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. RUBIO RUBIO. RUBIO
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO. SKINNER
STERN. STERN. AYE. WILK. OKAY.
14 TO 0. THE MEASURE HAS 14
VOTES, WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE THE
ROLL OPEN FOR ANOTHER MAYBE TEN
MINUTES. WE'RE GOING TO ASK
MEMBERS TO COME TO ROOM 1200,
AFTER WHICH WE WILL CLOSE THE
ROLL ON THE DAY'S AGENDA. YES DO
WE HAVE DODD OUTSTANDING ON
ANYTHING? LET'S CALL. WHAT WHAT?
ONE. SENATOR DODD. I THINK
THEY'RE MISSING YOU ON THAT. SO
CALL THE ROLL. AB 1918. TÍNH
CABALLERO. DODD DODD. AYE CIERTO
. SKINNER 15 TO 0 EMERGED AS 15
VOTES.
ALL RIGHT. SECRETARY, PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM ONE
AB 1918. HANG ON. I'M GOING TO
GET MY SPEAKER UP. WE'RE GOING
TO STOP. OKAY. AB 1918 DO PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HOUSING. CHAIR. VICE CHAIR.
VOTING AYE. 15 ZERO CURRENT
VOTE. CABALLERO CIERTO. SKINNER.
SKINNER. AYE. COR TÚI. SO 17 TO
0 17 ZERO. AND WE'RE STILL
WAITING FOR. CABALLERO.
CABALLERO COMING BACK TO
PRESENTING. I'M WAITING FOR
THEM. ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
COOL. ALL RIGHT, LET'S MOVE ON
TO ITEM KANSEN. CHAU AB 2708 ON
CONSENT. OKAY, CABALLERO CIERTO?
CIERTO. AYE. SKINNER. SKINNER.
AYE ALL RIGHT. I'LL FOLLOW ITEM
THREE. AB 2779. DO PASS AS
AMENDED. THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. I THINK IT HAS
15 VOTES. 14 RIGHT NOW. CURRENT
VOTE 14 ZERO. CABALLERO CIERTO.
CIERTO. AYE. SKINNER. SKINNER.
AYE. WILK. COLLECTION. NOW WE'LL
MOVE TO VOLUME FOUR THREE 8787
BY PATTERSON. YOU HAVE TO PASS
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS AND
VOTES, 1515 TO 0. IT'S 15 ZERO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CIERTO CIERTO. AYE. SKINNER
SKINNER. AYE. STERN AYE. OH,
SORRY. I WAS PLANNING TO HOLD
OFF ON THAT ONE. OKAY. IS IT TOO
LATE TO ABSTAIN? YES, YES. OKAY.
STERN NOT VOTING. SORRY SO 17 TO
0. WE CAN CLOSE THE ROLL ON THAT
COUNT. WE ALL RIGHT, SO WE'LL
LEAVE THE ROLL OPEN FOR ANOTHER
FIVE MINUTES FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
TO ADD ON. SORRY SORRY. THANK
YOU. IT'S OKAY. SO I DIDN'T CALL
YOU.
ONE THROUGH THREE. AND, FILE
ITEM FOUR IS ALREADY CLOSED. ALL
RIGHT, ALL RIGHT, WE WILL
RECONVENE THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON ENERGY, UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS. OH, YEAH. WE
WILL NOT BE ACCEPTING QUESTIONS,
SO WE'RE GOING TO REOPEN THE
ROLL ON ITEMS ONE, TWO AND
THREE. ITEM FOUR HAS BEEN
CLOSED, MADAM CONSULTANT, PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL, AB 1918 ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOOD TO PASS AND RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HOUSING. CURRENT VOTE 17 ZERO
CABALLERO. CABALLERO AYE. 18
ZERO, THAT BILL IS OUT 18 VOTES
TO ZERO. ITEM NUMBER TWO, THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. CABALLERO.
CABALLERO. AYE. 18 ZERO. CONSENT
CALENDAR IS OUT 18 TO 0. AND THE
LAST ITEM AB 2779. PETRI NORRIS.
CURRENT VOTE 16 ZERO. CABALLERO
CABALLERO. AYE. AND THAT MEASURE
IS OUT. 17 VOTES TO ZERO. THAT
COMPLETES OUR AGENDA TODAY. AND
WITH THAT TOUGH HEARING I THE
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED. THANK
YOU.